look who's messing with your ass again
didn't he
it was the other way around man where's
the video of that [ __ ] you still the
hero our Harlem right my cousin's
getting smacked around by the cops cuz
he has dreads every Jamaican ain't down
with Bushmaster hey you need to handle
this loop my little sister can't even
sleep at night what are you gonna do yo
I'm doing the best I can okay
look I'm sorry about you bredrin and I'm
a handle Bush mess I and young lady I
promise I'm gonna put a stop to all of
this anyway
wait no better than the damn cops damn
she got you that's some cold [ __ ] let's
go
and see you using your powers right
excuse me
see if I was bulletproof and strong I'd
be running [ __ ] I'd be like either
you've been to me while you lay down
Beach and if they didn't good drink out
us like straight flames for the [ __ ]
estate property and Game of Thrones do
not mix now are you high that she sounds
right
are you coming in as you never asked
[Music]
yo I'm Luke Cage don't test me
you know where to find me everybody
talking about Luke Cage like he's Jesus
I know I just elected Mike smoke the
bulletproof black man for the Hard
Rock's is a gentle boogeyman of their
nightmares you should get a snack with
this really guys I don't know we try it
man I know you can't keep doing what
you're doing I have no idea what you're
talking about
and believe me Luke Cage is nothing but
a man
eylem is mine
Daniel hate to see such a positive
brother like Luke age go down like that
you hurts you
you're not invulnerable Luke anyone who
can take you on bear and it can't be
good for Harlem
I gotta find him fish monster what makes
him so scary we hope you never have to
find out
it's rubbish mess don't copy
[Music]
I've seen raw but never burger sometimes
pretending to get [ __ ] done own doesn't
need a hero
it needs a queen the darkness that you
deal with every day
we can't conceal and behold it
don't let
just to be clear about the market for a
side - it says you're not my sidekick me
it's my show
[Music]
you